if your heart rhythm
is abnormal your doctor may perform
electro cardioversion in which
an electrical shock is used to
normalize your heartbeat
normally beats at a regular rate of
60 to 100 beats per minute this
stable and coordinated rhythm allows the
heart pumps blood
efficiently electrical signals that travel
through the heart control heart rate
these electrical signals
begin in a group of cells
called nodules and not atrial or
pacemaker the node but atrial
or bone node is in the wall of
the  upper right chamber of the heart
called the right atrium when
electrical signals reach the
heart muscle causing it to contract and
pump blood abnormal heart rhythm
is called arrhythmia during
atrial fibrillation the atrium flutters
due to chaotic electrical signals
in the heart  resulting in
irregular or abnormally
fast heartbeats  Due to the abnormal heartbeat,
blood may pool in
it, which may cause a blood clot to form.
If the blood clot enters the
systemic circulation, it
could cause a stroke
before the procedure. You will be connected
to an IV.  you will be
sedated so that you will sleep during the
procedure lace electrodes
will be placed on your chest to monitor
the electrical activity of your heart
once sedated special cardioversion pads or paddles will be placed
on the skin of your chest or on your chest
and back
these pads or paddles will deliver
an electrical shot through your
chest to your heart
the shot may be repeated several times until
your heart returns to its normal rhythm
after electrical cardioversion you
will be closely monitored in a
recovery room or  hospital coronary care unit
once
the effects of the sedative wear off and
you are in a stable condition you
can go home